in the Rick and Morty season 4 finale
Rick has this epic anime inspired duel
against Phoenix person the reborn BP it
is now pipi and Rick for the second time
the season gets rekt also shout-out to
the funny detail of him drinking from
his flask and immediately exiting his
digestive tube probably just there to
help him process alcohol more
effectively anyway long story short I'm
not surprised Rick didn't die we've seen
him survive catastrophic injuries before
but I'm more surprised that Rick didn't
pull out a secret weapon no not that
secret weapon gross get your mind out of
the gutter no birdperson himself tells
us that rick's catchphrase of Wubba
lubba dub dub means i am in great pain
please help me it's in bird person's own
language in fact so if Rick suddenly
said this in his final moments does that
mean Phoenix person softens and gives up
the fight against his friend nah too
sappy for the show
now if they'd realize their mothers had
the same name now that would have been
awesome
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show that will go on forever hundred
seasons films and theories films in
theories 100 hundred episodes theorizing
about films and theories and also TV and
YouTube theory and sometimes even book
theory comic comic comic series comic
series that's the thing films in 300
years it's the one certain part about
all of this as a hundred years hundred
years until the heat death of the
universe Rick and Morty hundred years
films and theories heat death of the
universe maybe you have to be drinking
whatever's inside Rick's flask to be
able to pull off a rant like that anyway
it was worth a shot
Citadel of theorists it's no secret that
I have long been a huge fan of Rick and
Morty and all things witty but Season 4
well I gotta say it really salvaged
itself in the end for me I got to admit
they didn't love the first half of the
season
sure I appreciated the mystery of the
cat the references to the honey maze and
getting introduced to the world of snake
jazz but overall it was missing a lot of
the character relationships that made
this show so special to me but now that
the season's over I can honestly say
that this was probably at least the most
meaningful season yet to happen and not
because of clones or the return of Tammy
or face-hugging aliens but because the
season was all about the characters
search for identity it was very much
like the second act of a three act play
we've established who our main
characters are in the world that they
live in and act 1 and now we see the
problems introduced into these people's
lives we see the toxicity that exists
inside these relationships we learn that
those who were once the butt end of our
jokes might just be the best off this
was a season where characters evolved
and changed and found new identities for
themselves and those who are unable to
grow ultimately got left behind but
where this all gets really juicy is that
season 4 it doesn't just represent an
identity crisis for each and every one
of our main characters it's also the
crisis of identity facing the show
itself facing the people who make the
show and understanding all of this is
what gives us a clue as to what we might
expect from season 5 so sit right back
in your laser-proof Wranglers and pour
yourself a nice Windies frosty Chino
because it's time to hitch a ride with
invisible theory
Matt Pat's it's a new franchise season
four sees every member of the Smith
family looking for and/or questioning
their place in the world or I suppose
multiverse for Morty his unquestioned
identity for the entire show has been as
a Rick's sidekick it's easy to forget
but season three ended with Rick and
Morty beating up the president so they
can spend a bit more time playing
Minecraft together sure there have been
hints here and there that their
relationship might be decaying he bails
on everybody
he left you to rot in a world that he
ruined because he doesn't care so if you
really want your grandpa back grab a
shovel the one that won't let you down
is buried in your backyard but season
four really took it all the way in
episode one the death crystal episode we
see more new choose not to revive Rick
instead opting to keep him dead and
prioritize himself dying at an old age
and his crushes arms episode 3 the heist
episode shows him opting to skip
multiple adventures with Rick in order
to pursue his own dream of writing a
Netflix heist pilot the dragon episode
is all about morty getting to go on
self-directed fantasy adventures where
he proves himself more capable in a
world where rick's technology is useless
until of course the show gives up on
that really cool angle and just gives
Rick godlike powers yet again not cool
in the episode primordius Morty rises to
become the leader of the glory so a
lian's in the vat of acid episode he
sees the limitations of Rick's plans and
stands up to him about it are you dying
of dementia when did you get so cocky
tonight and in both episodes 9 and 10
it's Morty and summer saving Rick's life
instead of the other way around up to
this point
Rick's scientific wizardry has always
seemed like a solution for Morty because
whenever they screw up they can just
teleport or change realities but Rick
and his bag of tricks are empty Morty
over the seasons but especially here in
season 4 has learned that they're merely
a means to avoid actually living a real
life they're irresponsible it's a lesson
that's reinforced in that vat of acid
episode when Morty learns through his
video game style reset button that life
constantly able to reset is pointless
and that it's the consequences of our
actions that ultimately make life worth
living living without consequences is
great but then I started wondering what
am i living for we are who we are
because of concert
soin morty rejects rick's offer to find
out which beth is his real mom in the
finale
it's him turning his back on Rick's
trickery in favor of living a more
normal consequential and thus a more
meaningful life the season started with
this R and all about Rick and Morty
adventuring together for another hundred
years but by the end of the season
Morty's decided to be his own person
outside of Rick's influence now that is
a character arc morty and summer we work
together that's that's our heart summer
is coming at her identity from the
opposite direction she's usually on the
outside of Rick and Morty's adventures
looking in but just like Marty she too
is looking to establish a new and
independent identity like any normal
teenager throughout season four we see
her trying new things to help define who
she is she's inexplicably carrying a
toothpick in her mouth it's a toothpick
I'm a toothpick er now get used to it
are you that desperate for a thing
trying podcasts running from match to
match on the love finders app what a
stupid name for that thing or just
getting into snake jazz snake yes it's
also clear from episode 1 that she still
feels left out and she wants to be a
part of the Rick and Morty duo just
joking around you just seeing if you
guys pay any attention to me but over
the course of the season we see summer
develop into her own woman she rules
over the glories of civilization she
becomes an all-powerful Archer she saves
Rick's life multiple times by the end of
the season she's found herself as strong
and independent she's happy to be
Morty's sister and she no longer needs
grandpa's approval she recognizes that
her family was living a fairly normal
life before Rick came in and disrupted
it and she's over him driving him apart
as she puts it in her last line of the
season grandpa Rick don't drag us into
your just because you're losing control
summers desire to be part of Rick and
Morty's adventures was never about
finding ways to act the universe was
always about being included now she
realizes that she can just team up with
Morty she can have that inclusion all
without Rick's destructive baggage
weighing her down of all the interesting
plots and subplots from season four one
that flew under the radar almost the
entire time was the revitalization of
beth and jerry's mayor
season three ended with Jerry back in
the family and Rick on the defensive and
now just one season later even Jerry has
found himself a new identity he is no
longer the worm that we saw him as in
season two
he's now finding strength against Rick
and is starting to reassert himself as
the man of the household provided he was
ever really the man of the household to
begin with let's be honest throughout
his season for adventures we see him
save his own life we see him lead a
civilization we see him save Beth's life
we see him save Rick's life in a
delightfully Jarry way save the day with
puppeting only one with a decent heart
most importantly of all though Jerry is
coming to realize that he doesn't need
to be the hero to be useful he might not
have had any soul mates on the love
finders app but Beth chooses him anyway
he might be a dork who glorifies camping
but his s'more stick ends up saving Beth
Jerry is aware that he's a what but he's
made peace with the idea that Beth and
his family are all he really needs to be
happy and when you look at that self
realization compared to the endless
misery and cynicism of Rick who can
never truly be happy Jerry is the one
who really comes out on top well I was
impressed dad he saved my life no thanks
to you which brings us to Beth who's
faced in season four with the most
literal identity crisis as she continues
to grapple with the idea that she might
be a clone and though we don't see much
of her this season even Beth has an
identity arc cloner otherwise she
transforms from the insecure
dissatisfied woman trying to numb her
pain in earlier seasons to a confident
mother I'm a mother you until your 18th
birthday even if I get thrown in prison
for non-consensual mothering and
skeptical but ultimately loving wife
look on the off chance that you use the
gap I didn't use it did you me no but
it's building a civilization with her
father that really sets the turning
point in her characters search for
identity early in episode 9 we see the
old Beth peek through as she delights
over the praise that Rick gives her
these kids may not be mine but you
definitely are my little
steampunk overlord and yet midway
through the episode Rick abandons there
just like he did to her when she was a
child to prove himself as a god against
another God which ultimately backfires
and in turn it almost gets Beth leaving
Jeri as the only one to save her by the
end of this episode
Beth's season arc is pretty much
complete well I was impressed dad he
saved my life no thanks to you and this
old culminates with the season 4 finale
where we come face-to-face with Beth's
clone or the original Beth honestly the
episode doesn't give us a whole lot of
clarity at the promotion for their video
game pocket Morty's after the episode
may have by calling space math clone
Beth in the game regardless the Beth's
conclude that it doesn't matter sure
you'd love for us to need that from you
but I don't care what's in that file
they've both found their identity 1
defined by not needing Rick's approval
they're strong in their own ways and
those ways don't include him leaving us
with Rick himself who was in pretty bad
shape at the end of the season Oh pat
myself on the back a little bit here
because I totally called the ending of
the season not too much because I also
made a video about how Rick didn't
actually clone method also whoopsie
there anyway
Rick is left broken and alone at the end
of the season for exactly the same theme
that we've been talking about with every
other character because instead of
finding a new identity like everyone
else
Rick refuses to change he recognizes
that he's a jerk to everyone and
everything around him but he just
doesn't do anything about it
he thinks that lamp shading it by
directly calling it out is enough but
it's not at least not anymore this is
him in season 3 bad father all the way
to the max over here now compare that
with his realization at the end of
season 4 I'm a terrible father Rick
historically was comfortable with the
fact that he wasn't a good dad because
he convinced himself that nothing
matters he's not entirely wrong about
that when humans are just a small speck
of dust in an infinite universe yeah our
actions are pretty meaningless on the
scientific level but when you're not
looking at the objective reality of the
universe and instead zoom all the way
down to the family level into the
subjective reality in which we all live
well then we're all the center of our
own little universe and it's there that
you're able to find true meaning true
purpose and true happiness
that is when your actions literally make
a world of difference but will Rick ever
be able to grow up and see that that is
the fundamental question hanging over
the rest of this show okay so our
characters are having a bunch of
identity crises throughout season four
but does that really tell us anything
about where the show is headed yeah a
lot because the crisis of identity that
the characters are having is clearly
mirroring the discussion that the makers
of the show are having about its
identity throughout this season - this
was the first season produced after the
series was picked up for 70 more
episodes and the pressure of how to
handle that many more installments of
the series while still maintaining what
made this show great in the first place
is the core arc throughout this entire
season for don't get me wrong
Rick and Morty being meta and break in
the fourth wall is nothing new it all
goes back to the pilot episode but it's
never been as specific as it's been in
season four we're almost every episode
that aired has some deconstruction of
what it means to make the show of Rick
and Morty it's most obvious in the story
Lord episode that we covered in great
detail already but there's so much more
to it and it all has one common theme
the debate over making the show
serialized or episodic serialized
television tells a single story from
beginning to end
usually in chronological order like Game
of Thrones or Breaking Bad pick up in
the middle of those series and you don't
have a clear idea of exactly what's
going on episodic television is often
seen as more formulaic and events from
one episode don't really affect all the
other episodes around it think the
Simpsons or Seinfeld or most seasons
South Park things happen but there's
always a reset button at the end of the
episode it's a debate that's set up from
the very first episode of the season we
end it on this rant sometimes we'll do
classic stuff you know other times we'll
do whatever do anything a direct
callback to a very similar speech that
happens at the end of the pilot episode
of the show when nothing mattered and
everything was just meant for fun and
that's not all in this very episode
kicking off season four we have facist
morty outright declare that he wants to
have fun classic adventures like in the
good old days you know it would really
help if you could just say anything
other than what you don't want I like
mr. meeseeks okay now we're talking here
fascist Morty is serving as the voice of
fans who didn't like the more serialized
route that the show was taking
throughout season three or the season
told an arc about Beth and Jerry's
separation and the fallout with the rest
of the family and Rick basically
responding with tell me something that
you do like is clearly a stand-in for
the feelings of the show's creators it's
them begging fans to stop complaining
about everything and instead offer them
something productive something they like
some constructive criticism about the
creative decisions that are happening on
the show so the first episode of season
four sets up this arc about the identity
of what the show is and we see this
debate play out throughout most of the
other episodes in the vat of acid
episode we get this exchange video game
style saving device yes Morty I saw it
on Futurama so you don't do anything
unless it's original in the first few
seasons Rick and Morty didn't have to
worry about being unoriginal because it
was presenting us with new characters
establishing its own style but now the
makers of the show have to continue to
make decisions about whether characters
and stories should reoccur how original
their concepts need to be and on and on
and on and we're seeing those debates
literally taking place on the screen
through the voices of these characters
in that very same episode we also get
this line there's no such thing as a bad
idea Morty it's about execution this
discussion of there being no bad ideas
is a frequent topic in groups of
creative individuals they even poke fun
of what many consider to be the weakest
episode of the series morty wanting a
dragon isn't an idea I'm not talking
about that I'm constantly pitching you
ideas Rick and us they're not even we're
thinking about this whole sequence isn't
just two characters arguing it's a
writers room debating what can and can't
be an episode of this show it's a debate
that we see embodied in other episodes
too by Jerry's mysterious cat in the
middle of the season a cat that
literally stands for everything not
needing an answer and just having fun
when Jerry asks why the cat can talk we
get yet another writers room ask quick
why are you talking why should that
matter why should it not matter of
course there's the story Lorde episode
which literalizes the fear that the
writer's team has of draining Rick and
Morty of all their story potential even
the final episode of the season has a
reference to this ongoing tension
the way she lived over serialised Tammy
like evil Morty and birdperson are too
important to the quote unquote plot of
this show and are thus in Rick's terms
over serialized they can't be episodic
characters they have to only take part
in episodes that are part of the serial
narrative every character in that last
episode talks at some point about their
arc and how important their arc for the
season was so how does it all shake out
what conclusion does the show reach what
is the show's meta arc for season four
well again we turn to that vat of acid
episode in it morty embodies both halves
of the serialized versus episodic debate
his reset button gives him the literal
ability to be episodic where
consequences don't matter he is
literally hitting a reset button but he
himself is a continuous serialized
entity continuing across all those
different timelines and having lived
both sides he comes to this conclusion
any show can be random smart funny but
it's the running threat of these
characters their relationships the
dramatic stakes that run through their
lives those are the things that make
Rick and Morty such an exciting show to
watch it's the consequences of these
characters actions that matter we'll
every episode from here before wording
the plot in some way no certainly not
Rick and Morty can have their cake and
eat it too
you can intersperse episodes about
fascist trampers snake terminators while
occasionally bringing back birdperson
or evil Morty or mr. meeseeks so the
identity that the makers of Rick and
Morty have settled on is what Rick
preached in the very first episode of
the season moderation on both sides so
what does any of this mean for the
eventual season 5 that'll come like
three years from now well we'll probably
still be seeing continuations of our
story developments morty and summer will
be teaming up for more adventures heck
it might feel more like summer and morty
than Rick and Morty and Rick will be on
outskirts all alone he'll be doing more
solo adventures maybe revisiting people
and places from his past as he tries to
prove himself to be a good friend heck a
good person
somewhere in his past and you know what
I don't think he's gonna find it he'll
find that almost everyone has a bad
taste in their mouths from their
interactions with him he's been knocked
down a few pegs throughout this season
he still
to be knocked down a few more in order
to finally force that true change the
seasons art will probably have to result
in Rick coming back to the family as a
changed man or the family being forced
to forgive him in some way and in order
to do that you really need Rick's
egotism to be shattered and then the
family can finally reunite and be
stronger together as a unit or you know
what who knows maybe Rick will never
redeem himself maybe he'll just be a
tragic figure doomed to his own misery
or they'll spend the next ten episodes
doing nothing after all they have 60
more episodes left that they're on the
hook for might as well burn through some
time with more stupid Morty dragon
adventures before getting into that
serialized heavy stuff they got to
stretch the storyline out a long time
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and cuts
you